Dungeons and action adventure video
games are a given in the modern day and
this is pretty largely due to the
influence of the Beloved Legend of Zelda
series I don't think there's a single
Zelda fan out there who doesn't have a
favorite dungeon or at least a memory of
one unless you were introduced to the
series from breath of the wild in which
case you might not know what a dungeon
is no matter how you slice it Zelda
dungeons are in and of themselves
Staples of the video gaming experience
so it's only natural that the dungeons
would also be a big deal as far as
storytelling and lore is concerned in
fact there's such a big deal that I
asked the man himself Nintendo black
crisis if he would be so kind as to help
me out with explaining all the Dungeons
and Twilight Princess and after he
finally returned my 50th caller so he
agreed everyone say hi well technically
it was only 49 calls but that's beside
the point this collaboration did give me
an excuse to replay Twilight Princess
though which was kind of amazing since
it was the one Zelda game I had only
ever beaten once and that was many years
ago with the Wii version as this is a
collaboration we've decided to split the
dungeons 50 50 meaning that each part
we'll talk about four of this game's
dungeons with the exception of talking
for now I didn't invite you over here so
you could take over the whole video be
sure to check out the other half of the
dungeon explanations over on his channel
after you're done here or hello and
welcome to the other half if you're
already coming from over there oh and
spoiler alert obviously for the first
Temple we'll be exploring in this video
let's start with the first temple of the
game the Forest Temple also take a shot
whenever we say temple on this video
just kidding that's a terrible idea any
fan who's played the game or who's ever
perused the forest section of the Zelda
Theory forums is no doubt familiar with
the symbolism present everywhere in the
Forest Temple and I'm talking
specifically about the Kokiri symbols on
all the doors but let's take a few steps
back real quick and talk about what the
Forest Temple even is the Forest Temple
itself is actually more of an entire
area or complex located within the Faron
Woods of intricately interconnected
colossal trees most of which are
hollowed out from the insides to make
way for all the various rooms and
bridges and doors and whatnot the
biggest question no pun intended is
what's up with these trees why are they
so massive and grown together like this
well let's take yet another several
steps back and talk about what Fair on
Woods is in regards to the rest of
Hyrule and see if we can get any clues
from that the previous game in the
timeline that actually deals with Hyrule
is Ocarina of Time and in that game
there is no fair on Woods on the map but
since this is the same Hyrule from
Ocarina of Time as proven by a direct
quote from anuma himself that means that
Twilight Princess is fair on Woods must
have originated from somewhere on
Ocarina of time's map of Hyrule the
first and most obvious guess would be
the Lost Woods area from Ocarina of Time
I mean that's also where the Kokiri came
from and it has a large Forest Area so
naturally this would be the most obvious
answer of course the Hyrule maps from
Ocarina of Time and Twilight Princess
don't exactly exactly match up one to
one which could raise some questions on
whether or not this really is the same
Forest area but we don't have time to
create an entire other theory for why I
will change this much in between games
so for now we're just gonna have to go
with the logic of forest equals Forest
if this is the case then not only does
that explain the Kokiri symbolism and
even the skull kid's appearance in the
nearby sacred grove but it also reminds
us that we have in fact seen a colossal
tree surrounded by Kokiri that's
hollowed out on the inside to make way
for rooms and bridges and doors that
being the great Deku Tree which I may
add is conveniently missing somehow from
Twilight Princess now obviously there is
a pretty massive difference in
appearance and size between the great
Deku Tree and the Forest Temple with the
latter actually being composed of
multiple giant trees but you've got to
admit the fact that they're both trees
along with the forest Temple's location
and existence of the Kokiri symbolism is
way too deliberate it to mean nothing at
all I mean it's actually rather obvious
that the Forest Temple from Twilight
Princess was meant to be an enhanced
version of the great Deku Tree dungeon
from Ocarina of Time the only question
is how and why is it the way it is well
let's once again cover a bit of
backstory from Ocarina of Time for more
context you see before link faces
Ganondorf as an adult before he spies on
him as a kid before the game even begins
Ganondorf has already infected the Deku
Tree with the parasite known as Goma at
the end of the game Zelda sends link
back in time creating the child timeline
that spawns the following game Majora's
Mask along with Twilight Princess one or
two centuries later however what we'd
like to point out in this video is that
we can actually see link after he sent
back in time when he meets Zelda for the
second first time and use this scene to
pinpoint exactly when he returned to
notice how she's spying on someone
inside her father's Throne Room exactly
what we saw her doing when we met her
the first time it can then be assumed
that she's doing the same thing and
spying on Ganondorf which means that
link was most likely sent back in time
to the same spot that we played through
near the beginning of the game and I'm
going over all this to state that it's
our belief that at this point in the
child timeline the Deku Tree had already
been infected by Ganondorf meaning the
Deku Tree probably still ended up dying
very quickly in the new child timeline
the Zelda spawned now one other thing
I'd like to mention is that the Deku
Tree preemptively planted at least one
new giant Deku Tree seed in advance
predicting its own death and given that
the Deku Tree could theoretically have
planted multiple seeds like we see it
doing in the Wind Waker all of a sudden
we've got a possible explanation for why
the Forest Temple of Twilight Princess
is composed of a bunch of colossal
hollowed out Deku tree-like trees it
might even explain how they're able to
grow to this size over the span of only
one to two hundred years if they really
are saplings of the original great Deku
Tree then they're kind of you know magic
they can grow pretty quickly as we see
actually on that note it could even just
be one Deku Tree perhaps even the
sapling we see in Ocarina of Time why
couldn't it grow into a huge nesting of
trees like the real-life pandoorganism
in Utah a giant forest system of
approximately 47 000 trees that all
share the same genetic code and a single
root system meaning they're all one tree
the last question is probably the most
obvious and that is why is this Forest
Temple not alive if it really is the
remnants of one or several great Deku
trees well this is just speculation of
course but the simplest answer seems to
be due to the corruption of the Deku
Baba plant that transformed into the
Hideous parasite diaba and introduced
monsters that drove out the Kokiri all
thanks to the fused shadow that was
placed inside for safe keeping
yeah turns out that was probably not the
greatest idea since a few's shadow piece
has corrupted every dungeon they were
placed in but this way of thinking
pretty much explains everything there is
to be explained about the Forest Temple
of Twilight Princess why it's located
where it is why it was clearly inhabited
by the Kokiri and how it was created and
subsequently abandoned also if you're
interested in the Kokiri side of things
Bandit actually did a theory recently
about that exact topic and how it ties
to the monkeys that currently occupy the
temple as well as the nearby Ordon
Village I believe it will be linked in
the description below if you'd like to
check it out next up we're actually
going to skip straight to the Arbiters
grounds because reasons whenever a Zelda
game introduces a darker themed dungeon
typically that dungeon instantly becomes
the fan favorite of the game and the
same is true of the arbiter's grounds
because it's got it all unnerving
atmosphere the undead enemies the
chilling soundtrack The memorable boss
and polenti of lore implications
literally everywhere so let's start by
explaining the name arbiter's grounds in
the original Japanese it's actually
referred to as sabaku no shokejo which
means desert execution ground of course
in English we refer to it as the
arbiter's grounds or the arbiter's keep
if you translate the Hylian text on the
map with the word Arbiter literally
meaning a decider especially in regards
to an argument or a trial in reality the
grounds themselves served both of these
purposes it was a large prison where the
worst criminals of Hyrule were tried and
sentenced mostly to death some to
banishment and others too both actually
but what is this place really who built
it and why is it out here in the middle
of literally nowhere well I'll tell you
what I think and the answer is
unfortunately not super cut and dry see
the symbols and imagery within the
arbitus ground seems to be a clash of
cultures on the one hand we have Hylian
culture depicted by the very familiar
Hylian Royal Crest and even symbols of
the sages who serve the goddess hylia on
the other hand we have Gerudo culture
with several statues depicting the
serpent-clad sand goddess who fans May
recognize from the desert Colossus and
spirit temple in Ocarina of Time as the
gerudo's deity that they presumably
worship even though that's an assumption
and has never been stated outright from
the Gerudo so in my opinion the
arbiter's grounds was built actually in
conjunction between the hylians and the
Gerudo and I also happen to think that
it's a very ancient Place honestly
largely due to its appearance alone I
mean I doubt this could all be built out
of Mighty Stone pillars and then turned
into ruins over the span of Amir one to
two hundred years which is the amount of
time aunuma himself States took place
between Ocarina of Time and Twilight
Princess there's also an old language
written on the walls of the arbiter's
grounds that to this day still doesn't
fit within any known language script
inside the Zelda universe meaning it's
most likely an ancient forgotten
language which wouldn't even be the last
time this game deals with ancient
forgotten languages but more on that
later what this all means is that the
arbiter's grounds most likely long
predates the events of Ocarina of Time
and when you think about it this way new
questions begin to arise such as were
the Gerudo and hylian's allies way back
in the day who built this giant Coliseum
together what if long ago in the ancient
age of Hyrule if you will the early
hylians and Gerudo were actually one and
the same this actually makes sense on
multiple different levels for instance
from the real-life modern understanding
of how Evolution works if you rewind the
clocks by a few Millennia cultures and
even species will be much less diverse
and in Universe we know that at least as
far back as in Skyward Sword the Gerudo
as a race did not exist yet what pretty
much proves they were all the same race
at one point now the combined ancient
hylians and Gerudo people the irudos if
you will would have still had their
royal family that follows the bloodline
of the Goddess hylia which stems from
the first ages of life on the surface as
alluded to in skyward's sword and as I
already mentioned hylians are named
after and are all the children of the
Goddess hylia so here's a thought what
if the goddess of the sand is actually
an early depiction of hylia herself
which the ancient hirudo architects of
the arbiter's grounds worshiped it's
female like Hylian the rest of the
goddesses and it's always depicted as
wrapped in a serpent which historically
has always symbolized fertility or life
it would also explain the strange
appearance of the Royal Crest Sage
symbols and goddess of the sand being
all in the same place which is otherwise
unexplainable and given that the Gerudo
and the hylians really were once the
same race I doubt that the sand goddess
would depict only one of the three
golden goddesses such as din which is
another popular consensus for who the
sand goddess is it's not like they
didn't know about the Triune nature of
the three golden goddesses I'm I mean
all three of them are depicted around
the Hylian Throne so in my opinion the
sand goddess being hylia herself
actually makes the most sense but now to
the next question why was it built as a
Coliseum isn't that a bit strange you
know for a prison even ancient prisons
were built differently with jail cells
and whatnot but a Coliseum on the other
hand only serves one purpose and it's
not exactly for imprisonment if you saw
my previous video on the boss lore of
Twilight Princess you probably already
know where I'm going with this but
basically my thought process is as
follows in the age following the first
Zelda and Link's repopulation of the
surface technology advancements most
likely took a huge dive plunging the
land that would eventually be called
Hyrule into its ancient ages and just
like our own real-life ancient ages the
royal family which are devout and
religious eventually constructed a
Coliseum in the leneru desert which is
the old Gerudo desert in order to honor
their goddess by way of gladiatorial
combat and before you think that would
never happen remember it did happen in
our own real life history and the royal
family of Hyrule has done many Shady
things behind closed doors for basically
the entirety of the history of Hyrule
case in point the Shadow Temple or the
onslaught against the sheikah in breath
of the wild eventually of course the
Coliseum was deemed immoral and
abandoned until years later when the
interloper War took place which as most
fans know ended with The Interlopers all
being subdued By the Light spirits and
subsequently banished banished where to
the Twilight realm banished how by way
of the mirror of twilight Atop The
Desert Coliseum and this is how I
believe the arbiter's grounds got its
name because it was at this point that
the fate of The Interlopers was decided
it's unknown how much if at all the
grounds was used following this event
but the next recorded criminal to be
processed at the grounds was Ganondorf
himself who was initially supposed to be
executed before the sages resorted to
banishing him as well not before he
claimed one of their lives though since
that day the arbiter's grounds has not
only been abandoned but has actually
forbidden to enter according to aoru but
that doesn't change the fact that there
are still powerful Spirits lingering
within its ancient halls but I won't go
into that here just is to avoid being
redundant if you would like to know how
those spirits and Zant and the various
Undead and Star-Lord and even Ganondorf
himself fit into the puzzle that is the
arbiter's grounds check out my Twilight
Princess boss lore video if you haven't
already one of the most interesting
takeaways from that video is that if you
look at on the lake bed Temple is one of
the easier dungeons to explain in the
entire Legend of Zelda franchise because
in truth it may actually be the second
appearance of the water temple from
Ocarina of Time just to follow suit with
Twilight princesses Hall taking Ocarina
of time's content and making a better
stick although there have been a few
things that happened to it in between
games to explain its different
appearance firstly we know it's the same
Temple as the old water temple because
it's Azora Temple located at the bottom
of Lake hylia seriously how many can
there be only one hopefully I don't
think we could take any more than that
but in all seriousness it's even roughly
designed the same way with multiple
Rising water levels and four directions
and a large Central piece in the middle
of the dungeon although now it's a giant
spinning staircase instead of a
multi-story room this isn't that I think
is important to note in this game is
once again The Disappearance of another
nature Spirit from Ocarina of Time the
water spirit jabu-jabu we know that the
lake bed Temple used to be a place of
worship for the Zora people back when it
was called the water temple and as
bandit theorized in the boss lore video
for Ocarina of Time It's very possible
that progressing through and completing
the water Temple's complexity was in and
of itself a form of worship for the Zora
people however if they no longer have a
water spirit to worship since jabu-jabu
is currently M.I.A then what other
purpose could the temple possibly serve
once again enter the fused Shadow Relic
since the light Spirits entrusted the
four pieces to the Kokiri Goron Sora and
apparently Gerudo or Twilight and since
we already know that the gorons built
Contraptions within their minds
specifically to ward off Wayward
Intruders from discovering the fused
Shadow held within which by the way we
go into in my video on my channel why
couldn't the Zora have done the same
with their water temple what better way
to serve the gods and provide worship
than to place a few's shadow Relic they
were sworn to protect within their
already complex Temple and Spruce it up
with some new puzzles and rooms and to
be honest it's a nearly foolproof plan I
mean even midna states that the place is
seriously confusing the Sora really do
have a knack for Designing the most
infuriating puzzles known to Hyrule the
last Twilight Princess dungeon that
we're going to cover in this part of our
collab is also probably the most
mysterious and Elusive of them all and
that would be the city in the sky but
don't worry I'm pretty sure we've got
this one all figured out at least as
much as possible given the elusive
nature of the lore let's start with what
the scholarly Shad who's obsessed with
the Uka tells us in game he states that
the city in the sky is the home of an
ancient race of Highly Advanced
pre-hylian people who were even more
connected to the gods than the modern
day hylians and we actually do meet
these people in game and they have one
of the most unfortunate designs in the
entire series say hello to the Uka the
ancient race of chicken people and I
can't tell if they look terrified lying
or funny according to Shad it was
actually the Uka who were responsible
for creating Hyrule although he does
admit that it's just a theory although
if it is just a theory and it's not
supposed to be taken as fact I don't
know why Nintendo would have included it
in the game but anyway what he says is
that while the people who lived on the
surface founded Hyrule proper as in the
city and Kingdom the Uka were busy
creating their flying City in the sky
after which they divested the Dominion
Rod to the surface dwelling hylians
should they ever need to speak with
their siblings in the sky there's more
backstory that we could go into
regarding the Uka and their Technologies
but I want to focus specifically on what
the city in the sky is and why it was
made in the first place now let me hit
you with another idea that may come as a
shock to you that branches off of what I
talked about in the arbiter's ground
segment what if it wasn't just the
hylians magruda that used to be the same
race what if all of the humanoid races
of Hyrule are actually each of the
different evolutions of the original
race of hylia people meaning the Gerudo
the Minish the Zoro the Rito maybe even
the gorons and the hylians themselves
all originate from a singular race that
lived with hylia law long ago in the
first era of the world before hylia's
battle with demise but due to living in
different environments and biomes and
with the passage of tens and even
hundreds of thousands of years they
evolved into their own separate races of
humanoids over time I mean in Skyward
Sword it's not like the Zora or the Rito
or the Gerudo exist yet so they must
have been evolved into there's not much
solid evidence to support this besides
the speculations I mentioned but just
bear with me the more you think about it
this way the more everything makes sense
and ultimately the more explainable the
city in the sky becomes see if all
hyruleans stemmed from a singular race
that then evolved into the different
races we know of today then that already
explains how modern hylan's evolved from
or rather simultaneously alongside the
Uka and it also explains why the Uka
wished to live in the sky because if
they share a history with what we know
happened with hylians in the past then
they used to live in skyloft alongside
their fellow Sky loftians which as we
know is a vital part of the history of
modern day hylians and why their Royal
Crest features a loftwing which is a
species of bird that has has since
allegedly gone extinct if this is the
case then wouldn't it be plausible that
just like some hyruleans decided to live
in the mountains some in the desert some
in the water and some in the grassy
fields that some would then decide to
live in the skies above like they used
to on skyloft another important thing to
note is that the ukha as they seem today
might not be how they looked when they
built the city in the sky in the ancient
times I mean just look at this thing I'm
pretty sure you need opposable thumbs to
build this stuff in fact an early
concept art for the race looked like
this which is much more human looking
with ape-like arms and feet while also
sporting feathers in a beat cat or maybe
that's a second face given that Twilight
Princess was developed after the Wind
Waker which featured the brand new race
of bird-like people known as the Rito
could it be that the ukha of Twilight
Princess are in fact the child timeline
variants of the Rito or maybe a branch
of the Rito thanks to this strange mural
that has been enhanced in Twilight
Princess HD we can see that the Rito did
exist at some point in the past and
right next to the panel depicting the
Rito we can see the Uka and and while
there are many theories that could be
derived from the single mural way too
many to get into in this video it does
seem to prove you the way that the Rito
existed in the history of the child
timeline but that begs the question if
they did exist where are they now and
furthermore what if what it depicts is
actually the passage of time for the
hyrulean people for instance the Rito
could have evolved from the earlier
Hylian and Goron races then they could
have split into the evolutions of the
Uka and Zora keep in mind that this
mural could be depicting ancient times
possibly an era well before Ocarina of
Time like I was saying though there are
many different ways to interpret this
mural this being just one of them and
I'm not trying to imply that I have it
100 definitely correct but for the
purposes of explaining the city in the
sky we're gonna go with this for now and
don't ask me about the little Link in
the mural I have no clue what he's doing
there but he do be kind of cute I guess
one way that we could explain the link
here would be what he did in between the
events of Ocarina of Time and Majora's
Mask perhaps he went around uniting all
the races of Hyrule some of which are
the Rito and the Uka although if you
think about it that could still be true
and fit with this explanation of this
City in the sky but anyway back to
explaining the city in the sky to
summarize it's our speculative belief
that it was probably created by an
ancient race of hylians that was a
combination of many of the hyrulean
races we see today which is why the ukha
are said to be the predecessors of the
modern hylians this ancient race may
have even been the retail or evolved
into the Rito or evolved from the Rito
there's a lot of different races
evolving to and from each other it's
kind of hard to keep track of it all but
anyway this explains why they have a
shared history with modern hylians and
why they wanted to live in the skies
above like they used to on skyloft and
given another large passage of time the
ancient Uka that might have looked like
the flying bird like Rito or maybe even
looked like this once then evolved into
smaller walking birds that now look like
this which is why they have at least one
humanoid feature remaining that being
their faces they never forgot about
their surface dwelling Hylian siblings
though which is why they created the
Dominion rod with the sole purpose of
uncovering the ancient Sky language and
thus enabling the holder of the rod
known as the messenger to the Heavens to
ascend to the city in the sky and
Converse with and that about wraps up
the explanation on the mystifying City
in the sky and apologies for getting
into some heavy speculation there like I
said it's got to be one of the most
vague dungeons in the history of the
series but given the pieces of evidence
that we do have in some what if
questions I think we've got a solid
explanation to use but we're not done
yet because that's only half of Twilight
Princess dungeons for the other four
head on over to Nintendo black crisis
Channel where you'll find our other part
live right now unless you're coming from
there too here in which case hooray you
made it to the end give yourself a pat
on the back thanks for watching everyone
always a pleasure being here talking
about the zeldas you should definitely
play this game if you haven't yet here's
hoping that Nintendo actually ports this
as well as Wind Waker HD to the switch
and if you want to see the other half of
this collaboration make sure to click
the link in the description thank you so
much for watching please consider
leaving a like if you enjoyed it or if
you enjoyed our efforts into making it
and subscribe if you haven't already to
stick around for many more deeply
interesting video game videos to come
huge thanks as always to my Bandit crew
of which Dr ohm 7 recently just joined
up and that's all I've got for this one
so follow me on my socials and I look
forward to seeing you over in the other
video this has Bandit going over there
[Music]